[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Jesse is
in Atlanta starting off this hour hi
Jesse how are
you I'm wonderful thank you for taking
my call how are you better than I
deserve what's
up so my husband and I have um they read
The Total Money Makeover and we worked
diligently to get out of debt and
thankfully now we've paid off our debts
and we own our home we are now in the
process
thank you uh it was actually through
your book God did amazing things through
you um but so now we're in the process
of looking towards wealth building and
because of that I've been looking at uh
podcasts and different videos on wealth
building but I've been noticing a
recurring theme among a lot of these
very well-known people and it's that
they use these phrases everybody has a
prenup either the government makes one
or you make one yourself um and I have
always been someone that thinks very
negatively towards prenups my husband
and I when we were married granted we
were broke but we always felt that the
word divorce was out of the question and
that if you're even considering a prenup
then you're opening yourself up to the
possibility of a divorce so I wanted
your opinion as a Christian as somebody
who is wealthy what is your uh
perspective on prenups especially in the
in the Christian room so it's more in
theory because it obviously doesn't
apply to you
all correct but to I guess the Reon that
I'm asking it is because I I it kind of
helps me in Discerning are these people
that I should get advice from like well
building is this people that I should be
listening to well I I don't know who
you're listening to and don't tell me
but um uh typically what happens in
something like that is a financial
person is the financial people and uh
legal people both uh are the world's
worst and I I had to break myself of
this when I started doing this several
years ago are the world's worst at
looking looking at life through only one
lens okay you're asking a question
through a relational lens a spiritual
lens and a wealth building and legal
lens they're only looking at it for
wealth
protection if if you could live a life
which you can't that wealth protection
was
separated from your relationships and
was separated from your spiritual walk
you can't but if you could
then a prenup would be a slam dunk and
in their minds therefore a prenup is a
SL slam dunk because they only see it
through that lens does that make sense
yes so I wouldn't necessarily discredit
them uh for all of their advice as
somehow being a heresy or something like
that I would just say whoever you're
listening to is only looking at the
advice they're giving through a singular
lens our approach is we believe that
personal finance is is 80% behavior and
we've proven that it's not about math
and it's not about that stuff so uh our
approach is is that the prenup actually
could end up uh stunting your growth
because you're not all in on working
together so when I first started this
show when I first started this show I
was 100% never get a prenup under any
circumstances don't get married if you
love your stuff more than you love her
period just don't do it that's how I
started now having done this a long time
I have one caveat that I've added about
a decade ago to this and that is if two
people are getting married one of them
has extreme wealth there's an extreme
difference like I had one guy um who was
marrying a lady who had $10 million and
he didn't have two
nickels okay I suggested a prenup to
them uh to keep their relationship pure
about relationship and not about money
and the bigger reason I suggested it to
them is my now experience 30 years later
has been the prenup in that case is not
really for that couple it's for all the
weirdos in their
families because all of the sudden crazy
mother-in-law swoops in from the other
side once the $10 million golden Goose
shows
up and you got to look at then you got a
little piece of paper and you look at
her and go sorry ma got a prenup can't
do
nothing and so it gives them a defense
mechanism against crazy in their family
cuz one thing we know about wealth is it
magnifies everything and that includes
crazy so when you got crazy members in
your family and you marry 10 million
dollar dad gum the crazy comes out you
know so in that case I did recommend men
a prenup in extreme differences but from
99% of the people just regular folk
getting married and you know I had one
lady call me up one time and said her
boyfriend had a 1968 frame up
restoration Mustang and he wanted a
prenup and you know my answer to that is
don't marry this bozo he loves his car
more than
you you know that's not that's the
that's the answer to that and that's not
a you know that might not jive with
these other guys podcast or whoever it
is you're listening to but um most of
the time I agree with where you're
coming from Jesse and that is the prenup
is simply planning the divorce in
advance oh oh 52% of the marriages end
in divorce no they don't no they don't
not when you take out people with
four-year degrees not when you take out
people who regularly attend a house of
worship not when you take out people who
the parents on neither side were
divorced when you take those statistics
out almost 90% of the people make their
marriage
work oh and you're a you're older than
22 years old and you didn't have a baby
before marriage you can take these
things out boom boom boom boom boom
success rate of marriage goes way up you
make $50,000 a year or more household
income you didn't have a baby before
marriage you didn't get married in high
school you know all these kind you take
all that crap out you got about a 90%
survival rate of marriages so that 52%
figure includes a whole bunch of other
crap going on of people who weren't
going to make it anyway so you can't use
52% of marriages and a divorce cuz I
really don't Jesse I'm going to ask Dave
a question on your behalf is that cool
yes um so Dave let me throw a caveat in
here tell me what you think about
this um a 55-year-old who's done pretty
well not extreme wealth um spouse passes
away and a Mary's a 57-year-old who's
done pretty well spouse passes away both
have kids both have cousins does it make
sense in that situation again to protect
from family and if you if you wanted to
but you've just got to be very careful
because it's a you you're entering
you're you're trying to say this stuff
the distribution of this stuff is more
important than this
relationship and man that's dangerous
and so if you don't have an ex basically
if you don't have an exit ramp we got to
figure this out yeah we got figure it
out yeah a good I mean if you don't
trust her to leave your Bible to your
son from the first marriage whose mom
died then don't marry her then don't
marry her right you know that's what I'm
saying and so I there's a whole thing
that goes into play here but yeah by and
large I'm anti- preup that would tell
because I believe you're planning your
divorce believe you're asking for
trouble and you know it's it's cheapens
the whole Affair and puts a dollar
figure to it and I just I'm not doing
that now if there's extreme difference
like I said there's a few times it's
okay you talk about it but it's it's a
dangerous thing thanks for the question
it's a good one create your free every
dollar budget today the simplest way to
budget for your life